[Musique]
casseroles de neuvième année du corps de 11e année je
fond et c'est mon meilleur ami nous sommes meilleurs
amis depuis le jour de ta naissance
comment sommes-nous restés si proches nous avons un
ensemble de règles comme la règle numéro deux ne jamais
dire à personne d'autre nos secrets  ou la règle
numéro neuf, le frère aîné de Lee, Flynn, a un
goût stupide mais totalement interdit
quand avez-vous bu de l'alcool oh et la règle
numéro 10 n'enfreint jamais la règle numéro
neuf, vous savez que le conseil étudiant
s'attend à ce que notre idée pour la collecte de fonds d'
aujourd'hui ne soit absolument pas mon  famille
tu n'as aucune expérience avec des gars
tu n'as même jamais eu de petit ami à
propos d'un tour il y a une fille qu'est-ce que je peux
avoir sur ce truc comme une de
tes filles de maquillage elles sont toutes embrassées avec
moi d'accord alors comme 95% d'entre eux font  sortir
avec moi
[Musique]
tu sais quelques jours pourquoi ça vient d'un garçon
J'ai décidé que je devais te voir ici
Je pensais que j'étais juste le
meilleur ami ennuyeux de ton frère ouais il
y a quelque chose qui se passe entre vous
deux
personne ne peut savoir à  du moins jusqu'à ce que je
vous dise qu'il
n'y avait rien de plus important
que de suivre les règles, mais dans la
vie, mesdames et messieurs, vous
pouvez soit suivre les nouvelles, soit suivre
votre cœur, hé, n'oubliez pas que nous
sortons samedi et j'ai invité  les
Evans me rendent service cette semaine à elfe,
elle a un peu le béguin pour toi
[Musique]
toi